do you think
aliens have communicated with our
government
explicitly yeah i'm curious about that
myself
i'm not sure i i think it's i think look
it's step one time man
step one is the general public needs to
get
caught up they need to get caught up
with the fact that the ufo presence
is real that we are being visited
on a regular basis by an intelligence
that our flying hard craft that are
far outpace our technology and we think
we know how they work
our government thinks they know how it
works
they can't replicate it as far as you
know there's no documents that say that
the aliens have explicitly communicated
with usa
or russia there's nothing that i would
concretely say you know a classified
document that i would say
that's probably real i i have obtained
documents that say as much but
the the the authenticity of these
documents will always be in question
because you can't trust
the source and the documents are they
implying some sort of collusion between
the aliens
and the government or is it something
else okay so
anybody that wades into the ufo world
really
really needs to protect themselves from
disinformation
there have been active programs of
disinformation
that have been admitted to by
our government so as far as i know
there's project blue book
is that what you're referring to no no
is that different
well okay so this is important project
blue book was
the it ended in 1969 supposedly
it was the united states government
study
of ufos now what people don't know is
that or a lot of people don't know
is that there were two ufo study
programs before
project sign and project grudge
sign as in sine wave or s sign
sign project sign and project grudge
and then it was project blue book and
this is the one that's very famous
that everybody knows about where the uf
where the us government said
the famous saying where jay allen
heineck who ran
project blue book said that he you know
one of the ufos was swamp gas you ever
hear that oh it's probably swamp gas
it's a
it's a very famous like thing that
people say to debunk ufos
jl and hynek who who ran project blue
book
later apologized for that because he he
knew the ufo topic was real
and he was mandated to
quote unquote demystify the ufo topic to
the public
so project blue book was a sham and now
everybody knows that
that there there are cases that they
can't describe but their
mandate was to try to calm the american
public
and this goes back again i'm sorry i
have to cut you off because i'm trying
to understand this so there's project
blue book
and what that was was a disinformation
campaign by the
american government ultimately
ultimately ultimately
it's been revealed that it was
at best a disinformation project
in that this was the official study of
ufos by the united states government
and people involved in that
process like j allen heineck later
revealed
that their mandate was to suppress the
information
was to minimize it was to come up with
prosaic
explanations and this is what that term
swamp gas comes from
now our government the united states
government also told
us that our study of ufos ended
in 1969. we now know that to be a lie
i told you about osap and i told you
about atip
those programs have now been
acknowledged
so our government did not stop studying
ufos of course they didn't they
represent a technology
that's far superior to what we have we
want that technology
whoever gains the technology that that
is shown
in these ufos they win
they win everything it is a technology
that cannot be competed with
it can be weaponized if these things do
travel using gravity wave amplification
if that's true then this can be
weaponized